genre genre janot nous occuper jeannot
janon le réac et j'ai déjà mon la
thrombine comme on l'appelait étouffée
dans son sommeil par un glock terreux
c'est une sommité
mais c'est aussi un père un grand père
et même un arrière grand-père un que
nous pleurons ce soir consiste à dieu
jamais étouffé par tong l'air à présent
je vais demander à gilbert est le frère
de joe no 1 des de venir nous parler de
cet ami de ce frère donc gilbert je vais
te demander de devenir ainsi dire que tu
un peu vieux lui aussi alors je mets
aussi monsieur le curé meslier alors
dans le micro les jeux barbe est alors
alors alors alors alors alors mon gâteau
jamais s'ils te dire que je t'aime mais
aujourd'hui 108 août qui arriverait
pauthe
j'ai envie de tous de te le dire vu oui
j'adore je t'aime tu vois tu aurais dû
mourir plus tôt pour me l'entendre dire
en a 80 ans bombail 80 piges les têtes
elle tua capec tapie qui comme elle
paraît que tout ce que tu t'es foutu
dans la gueule du total se profile pas
non plus c'était quand même la moindre
des choses
enfin alors donc quand je termine notre
visa d'or donc seigneur jésus marie
promet lui est réservé être prend soin
de lui à et surtout garde le prétoire
pas de blague n'en veut plus pas de
résurrection
merci gilbert bercy longwy les jeunots
entendu les messages d'amour que tu lui
envoies
amour amour amour amour l amour comme tu
t'en part de nos coeurs comme ça nous
cause bien des emmerdements
voilà une petite horizon punaise que
j'ai fait pour janot 1 jean d'ormesson
voilà cet exercice
merci merci beaucoup de ces gens vous
avez lumière du verdict à manger
bienvenue devant janot oui et c'est tout